Well, good morning again, church.
Uh, I can't tell you how much I was looking forward
to being together today.
Uh, we always need to be held up by brothers
and sisters in the church,
but some days you just feel it more than others.
And so today is one of those days,
and, uh, many of you have been aware that over the last
few years, uh, my family, extended family has been going
through, uh, a long season
of trial involving my older sister.
And so some of you don't know,
some bring you up to speed a little bit.
Uh, this is a picture of her
with my hero grandpa at her high school graduation.
And, um, 15 years ago
after having her second child, my sister had a stroke
that no one could explain.
And so it affected her movement a little bit on one side,
but mostly her personality changed.
And, and so it wasn't terribly bad.
But then six years ago, it was a,
another stroke, much bigger this time,
and one that changed the course of life for her
and for her family and for our extended family.
Uh, it was actually on a Sunday morning
and, uh, six years ago, I, I preached and then we left
and went to the hospital in Tulsa to see her.
And so she spent months in the hospital,
extended specialty care.
For a long time, she never really gained her ability
to speak back
and, uh, demanded 24 7 care more or less.
And, and then just, yeah, uh, in
and outta the hospital repeatedly over the last six years.
And so a couple times we thought this was the end,
and then she'd come back strong.
And, and just a few months ago though, uh,
it finally became clear that her body was shutting down.
And, uh, till just a couple days ago, Friday evening,
she died peacefully bringing to an end that, uh,
long journey of suffering.
And so, uh, many of you have prayed for her
and for our family over the last six years.
And just wanted to say, I can't tell you
how much that's meant to us.
Um, really say thank you
for you who've journeyed that with us.
It's been a, a long journey,
but incredibly encouraging
to watch the body be the, the body.
Uh, it, it's hard, a very public position of course.
And so it's hard to, to suffer privately, uh,
when you can't hide some things.
And so to watch church become
deeper church together has been neat.
So thank you for that. But it has required a lot from her
husband, from my mom, from her kids, uh, a lot
of other people like just to watch so many people
really dive in and care for her and, uh, support us
and them along the way.
It's been neat to watch that,
but especially I wanted
to highlight two people in this journey
that I've been really thankful for.
My, my brother-in-law, uh, her husband, you know, if you've,
if you know anything about strokes and,
and, um, traumatic brain injuries, often the spouse,
not often, sometimes the spouse doesn't stick around.
Uh, it's hard. It's really hard.
And so my brother-in-law has stayed steady
and I'm thankful for that to care for my sister.
Well, and then my mom, uh, she,
I've talked about my mom a lot
because she's an incredible warrior for the Lord
and for me and our family.
And she has walked this journey with such joy, uh,
not through no tears and, and pain and sorrow,
but she has walked this road with, with a measure
of hope and joy.
And, um, so this week,
if you'd keep us in your prayers, Thursday's, the funeral.
So I say all that because it's really funny how God works.
If you were here six years ago on
that morning, our stroke happened.
We, I preached and we left,
but we just happened to be that summer.
It was nearly six years ago, like two weeks ago.
That summer was when we started this decades long
journey through the Psalms.
If you remember, we started it way back then.
Uh, Psalm two was that morning.
But then that week we didn't know was she
gonna make it all this process.
The next Sunday was Psalm three,
just going through an order, right?
Psalm three is the first Psalm of lament.
And God just set it up for us.
Like here, we're gonna lament together.
I was grieving, we were grieving, you were grieving with us.
And so God just set that up.
And, and, and I shouldn't be surprised
because today, like
we're walking through Romans 12 months ago, we set up
what we're gonna preach in order and these kind of things.
Last week was all about rejoicing in hope.
Something more eternity, future we can have joy today.
Well, today we're talking about patience
in the middle of tribulation.
I don't think this is an accident.
The Lord In his funny sovereignty worked all this out
for us today to talk about how we can endure
difficulties, how we can wait well
through the trials of life.
I shouldn't be surprised, but here we are.
And here's why this is important, not just for me,
like again, this is, this is just raw, right?
Uh, it's important for me to hear these things
and to believe these things
and to be remind these things of course.
But it's important I think for all of us
because I've heard it said this way.
You're either coming out of a trial in the middle
of a trial or about to go a trial
like every one of us has been
is or will suffer.
Difficulties will come. It might not be as heavy as
as a, a family loss or,
or persecution directly or world war.
It might not be any of that stuff.
But all of us, none of us are immune
to difficulties coming our way.
I mean, Jesus said it himself, John 1633.
He said, in the world you will have tribulation.
Not you might you will. Trouble will come.
Difficulties will come for every one of us.
And if that's true, then we better
know how we're gonna handle it.
We better know what we're gonna do to, to be able to endure
underneath the trial that's coming.
And we can do that with joy and with hope
and with with faithfulness when it happens,
we better know how to handle that.
We have to pre decide how we can handle that.
Build up the faith we need, almost like vitamins today so
that when the things come later we can handle it.
How we can be patient in the middle. That's the question.
'cause here's the other option. Like we can,
we can pursue that.
Or the other option is
that we could crumble when the hard things come.
We could bail on faith.
We could bail on all of this
because our life isn't comfortable like we
hoped God would make it.
That that's really, I mean those are extremes.
Those are two options we have really.
And so today we're gonna see this,
this side patient endurance.
That's what we want. And how
that patient endurance reveals true faith actually reveals
it to us and to the world.
But also it is actually how God sanctifies us.
How he reveals his glory to the world is by changing us
in the middle of the journey through trials.
That's why this is so important.
And we'll especially see that as we look at Romans 12,
verse 12, just the second phrase of that verse.
We're gonna keep going phrase by phrase
through this chapter.
But what we're gonna see, the phrase is be
patient in tribulation.
We're gonna look at what
that word be patient meant originally.
It's gonna teach us a lot about this idea of endurance
Because, 'cause we hear patience
and we might think like just, you know,
sitting at a red light, being able to not get angry.
Like that's yes, but we're talking about something more than
that because that word be patient originally meant
to remain under like an umbrella.
If you want to remain dry, you remain under the umbrella,
but, but actually it's also to remain under a trial,
remain under a difficulty, a, a struggle,
a test you are facing that you're not looking to escape it,
not just looking for the way out,
but in a God-honoring way, you are eager to learn the lesson
that it was sent to teach you
that bravely, calmly you endure.
That's what it means to remain under, to be patient.
And really that kind of active endurance
is a litmus test for authentic faith.
Said another way, it reveals the genuineness of your faith.
Like to remain steady, to remain underneath,
to remain under the trial is, is endurance
showing faith?
Is it genuine or not? Is it real or not?
If God has allowed this trial in your
life for a purpose, right?
God doesn't do anything without a purpose.
If he's allowed this in your life for a purpose,
will you remain under it as you trust him, as you look
to him and say, okay, God, I don't understand,
but I'm gonna trust you or will you bail?
Because sadly,
not all faith is true.
Faith, you might have heard the news
all the time, talk about people of faith around the world.
Well if they have faith, quote unquote in a false God
or in a false picture of the true God,
that's not gonna sustain them.
That's not true. Faith, that doesn't last.
That's not sufficient.
So not all faith is true faith.
This reveals the genuineness of it.
But you also, not only just people of faith
around the world, you also have many people within churches
who don't have true faith
because sadly there's been a lot of false gospels presented
in America especially
that just says something like God's this cosmic vending
machine that if you just pull the right levers
and have enough faith, enough belief, then God will give you
whatever you want, healthy, wealthy wise, all those things.
He'll give it to you. If you just have enough belief you
believe hard enough, listen,
that doesn't have any framework for difficulties.
It doesn't have any framework
for when trials come in your life.
It only causes doubts
'cause then you're like, I'm questioning
myself at that point.
I don't have enough faith 'cause I'm having a hard time.
That is false.
Or maybe you have people sitting in churches all
around our country, especially who,
because it's easy to be a Christian in America.
That's why they believe. When you got places
around the world where it's really hard, it's costly
to believe in Jesus, to follow him, to say,
you're a Christian, they have to be all in.
We don't have that here.
And that breeds this churchianity kind of feeling that
that isn't true faith.
Because here's the reality, true faith endures.
True faith endures.
Now, I'm not saying you can't ask questions,
I'm not saying it won't feel really dry
or dark like it does right now for us as a family or,
or it might not hurt a little bit.
It might have to question some things,
but patient endurance through it all it,
it reveals a couple things.
When you're patiently enduring trial, it shows
that your faith is rooted in something much
greater than circumstances.
We talked about that last week with this.
This joy and hope that you have a hope
and something that's not just all of this work
and outright everything's gonna be like I want it to be.
No, my hope is in eternity.
My hope is in a risen savior,
a resurrected, ascended savior.
My hope is in a return of God
to bring his kingdom on earth as is in heaven.
That's my hope. That's where we can patiently endure.
It shows our hope's not here.
This is not good. This is painful, this is hard.
My hope's not here. Patient endurance reveals that.
It also reveals that you believe God's promises more than
you see your present pain in, in how it affects you.
Like you're able to say whatever hardship I'm
experiencing, it won't win.
It might win in this temporary life,
but it won't win when Jesus returns,
it won't win on the other side of death.
Pain doesn't win, death doesn't win. Jesus wins.
He already has and he will.
Whatever hardship doesn't have the final say.
That's what patient endurance shows the world.
It also reveals your treasure's in heaven. Not here like if.
If you're really focused,
if I'm really focused on just making sure everything orders
out and works out here, my treasure's here,
which means my heart is here.
Jesus says, no, we want a treasure to be in heaven
where our heart then is in heaven.
It's with him. It's something that can't be touched
by circumstances or world wars or cancer in this world.
It's beyond our treasures in heaven.
If we are patiently enduring, whatever comes our way today,
we have a treasure in heaven not here.
And finally, it reveals that Christ
is more precious to you than any easy life would be.
I love how the apostle Paul wrote it.
Philippians one 20
and 21 May Christ be honored in my body,
whether by life or by death, for to me to live as Christ
and to die His gain, like his whole goal.
He's like, I just want Christ to be honored.
I don't care what happens to me, whether I live
or die, whatever comes my way, Christ be honored,
Jesus over everything.
That's what he was about. Do whatever you want to me.
As long as Christ is
honored, is that our perspective?
Again, patience in tribulation is one
of the major tests of genuine faith.
I mean Jesus said it multiple times. This is one example.
Mark 13. 13, the one who endures to the end will be saved
like the one who remains under everything God
allows, doesn't bail.
Just says, okay God, I'm in. I'm in.
I don't know what this is. I don't like this, but I'm in.
I believe you. I believe you're better. I'm in.
Lemme just think of Job.
The Old Testament example of job that God allowed Satan
to test job in massive ways
Like job job's.
A wealthy man like Job is the picture of everything
American dream wants, right?
He's got all the money, he's got a great
family, he's got the reputation.
He's known well for being.
He's got it all together
and then God allows Satan to test him
and he loses everything.
He loses his children. He has boils on his skin.
All of that. And yet listen to job,
job 1315.
Though he slay me, I will hope in him
like even if
the worst thing comes where I am killed,
I'm gonna remain under the trial
because I'm trusting my God for resolution.
I dunno what it looks like. Even if it means I died.
The resolution is I get to be with him.
I'll see my redeemer face to face.
He said later like, that's his hope not in man.
I hope I get my family back. I hope I get my stuff back.
No God, I'm trusting you.
Even if it means the worst, I'm trusting you.
I will praise you in the trial
or or think of how God's word describes people
who are killed for their faith.
This is the, the word martyr is thrown around.
That's what people are killed for their faith.
Revelation 12, 11 says they loved not their lives,
even unto death.
Like They counted their life as nothing, even
with the the whatever coming their way
that was about to take their life.
Like, ah, that's not it. I'm gonna die. This isn't it?
This isn't all there is. I love him more. I love Jesus more.
I see Jesus better. I'm willing
to endure whatever it is here because Jesus is better.
Is that our perspective?
And so think about what kind of trials
and tribulations are you facing right now.
Could be any number of things, right?
I don't know all the stories in this room.
I know some, but like what are you facing right now?
What trials, struggles, tribulations,
difficulties are you facing right now?
It could be a whole lot of things.
Doesn't have to be as big as this that I'm talking.
It could be all kinds.
What are you facing when you think about your
response to those difficulties though?
What is that teaching you about the depth of your faith?
How Are you responding to those trials?
Are you remaining under it with joy?
Maybe not always a smile on your face, but
but with hope in the Lord.
Are you remaining under it? Say,
God, okay, I don't understand.
I'm gonna follow you.
Or are you complaining?
Are you wanting to bail? Are you doubting God's goodness?
What's your response show about the depth of your faith?
I once heard somebody say it this way.
I never understood that Christ was all I needed
until Christ was all I had left.
Everything else is gone. Everything is stripped away.
All you have is Christ. That's when you learn.
He's All, all I needed anyway.
Take all this others, take the rest of it all.
I don't need anything but him.
He is sufficient and so lean into him.
But listen, I get it. I'm not standing up here
saying, I got all this figured out.
I'm in process with you.
And it can be difficult to endure sufferings,
to endure tribulations patiently.
Especially when you have trouble seeing the purpose
day to day, right?
We ask that question a lot over the last six years.
Like, what? What? What are you doing? God, why? Why?
That question? Why comes up a lot, doesn't it?
Well, I wrote this down because I need to remember this
and I assuming you need to remember this too.
Those trials and tribulations that we face
Are Not meaningless in the economy of a good God.
They're not just happenings, they're not just stuff.
They're not just hardship. They are with a purpose.
And so, so listen, the main
hardship is God's workshop
for spiritual formation in our lives.
It's one of the main ways that God uses to refine
us into the image of Christ.
And when we patiently endure, we take this up,
we remain under it, we patiently endure
and we're walking through it.
That's how God is accomplishing
that refining work in our hearts, in our lives.
That's what he's doing. It's how he's doing it.
Like they're his tools. This is his workshop.
Trials are God's purposeful tools
to conform us into the image of Christ.
They're not meaningless.
It's the primary way that he is realigning us, right?
He's realigning us back to the perfect vertical of Jesus.
His trials. It's sufferings.
That is the primary way He does
that 'cause.
Think about how he does it.
Think about what he does through trials in our lives.
He uses tribulations to make us more humble.
Again, it's hard for me to suffer privately.
You've seen this over the last few years, right?
The vertigo thing, When I had vertigo for months,
God was using that to humble me.
My knee year and a half, still not right.
Like what's going on there? I don't know.
But you know what God was teaching me?
He's saying, Hey, stop trusting yourself, brother.
Stop trusting your body being right.
Like it's not about that. It's it's about me. My strength.
In fact, this is what Paul says.
Second Corinthians chapter 12, listen to how he says it.
So to keep me from becoming conceited
because of the surpassing greatness, the revelations,
a thorn was given me in the flesh, a messenger of Satan
to harass me, to keep me from becoming
conceited, to humble me.
He says, now notice it's not wrong to pray for
that thorn to be removed.
Three times I pleaded
with the Lord about this, that it should leave me.
It's not sinful to to plead with the Lord to remove pain.
It's okay, but watch the response.
But he said to me, my grace is sufficient for you,
for my power is made perfect in weakness.
Therefore, Paul says, I will boast all the more gladly
of my weaknesses so that the power
of Christ may rest upon me.
He has to humble us so that his power can show off more
through our weakness.
Why do we stand up here and think,
why do you stand up in life and think like, man,
I gotta put it all together.
I gotta make sure everybody else
thinks I have it all together.
No, his powers made perfect through our weakness.
Trials humble us so that he is shown
to be more and more powerful.
Trials conform us in our character.
This is how Romans five, three through five says it.
Not only that, but we rejoice in our sufferings
knowing that suffering produces endurance.
Endurance produces character. And character produces hope.
And hope does not put us to shame
'cause God's love's been poured into our hearts
through the Holy Spirit who has been given to us.
He's making us more like Jesus through suffering,
which then leads to patient endurance, which leads
to character characters like Jesus leading
to our hope being in something more than this world, right?
That's what he's doing. He's doing that through suffering
and he's doing it so that we would know Christ more deeply.
And we know Christ more deeply
as we actually share his sufferings.
That's Philippians three, verse 10 that I may know him
and the power of his resurrection.
We want that of course, and may share his sufferings
becoming like him in his death.
So you see God's good purpose in trials.
He, he's got a purpose.
We can't bail on the process though,
because if we bail on the process, we short circuit
what God was intending to do in our lives through the pain.
That's why I love James chapter one verses two through four.
It talks about this process.
He says, count it all joy my brothers, when you meet trials
of various kinds, I count it joy.
Do we do that? Hey, here comes a trial.
Yes. Like, is that what we're no. Or like, that's not us.
But watch this counter at all joy.
When you meet trials of various kinds for you know
that the testing of your faith produces steadfastness
endurance and let steadfastness have its
full effect that you may be perfect
and complete lacking in nothing.
It sounds like remaining under the trial, right?
Like Romans 12 says, remain under it.
Let it have its full effect. In other words, don't bail.
Let it work. Let it do what it's going to do. Why?
Because you want what God is intending for you to have
that you would be full, complete,
lacking nothing in your spiritual life.
How do you get to that point? You gotta walk the journey.
You gotta walk the process.
You can't, like Mario Kart shortcuts across the the river
to get to the, my kids were beating me by like 30 seconds
and I don't know how they shortcut everything, okay?
But this is what we can't do in life.
We can't short circuit
shortcut the work God is doing in your life
because then you're gonna miss what God is teaching you
Through it.
And I know, I know that can hurt. It can hurt real bad.
That's why I love Hebrews the way Hebrews
12 verse 11 says it.
This is talking about disciplining our sin,
but think discipline of, of formation of life.
It applies here, watch this for the moment.
All discipline seems painful rather than pleasant.
But later it yields the peaceful fruit of righteousness
to those who have been trained
By it.
Like that's, that's a process training.
It's not fun in the middle of it,
but it yields fruit on the other side in big ways.
You might not be aware of how they refine and purify gold.
I didn't, so I had to look it up.
There's a process called the miller process.
'cause gold doesn't come outta the ground pure.
It has impurities in it.
And so what they do is they, they put
that crude gold in a container and then they heat it
and they melt it down.
And then they treat that with chloride
because the chloride mixes with the zinc
and the copper and the iron.
That's all in that crude ore.
And those things link to the chloride.
And what that does is it leeches out of the gold as draws.
And so as it's heated up, that stuff rises to the surface
and they scrape it off.
And what is left behind progressively more pure
gold, heat it up, melted down,
mix the chloride in there.
It leeches out the bad stuff. They scrape it off.
More pure, more pure, more pure gold.
Listen to one Peter one
verses six and seven describe a similar process
in our lives in this.
You rejoice though now for a little while if necessary.
You have been grieved by various trials
so that the tested genuineness of your faith
more precious than gold, that perishes, though it is tested
by fire, may be found a result in praise and glory
and honor at the revelation of Jesus Christ.
Did you see what he said?
He said, God is using the trials in our lives as the heat
to refine us
and purify us, removing the sinful dross in our lives
so that we look progressively more like Jesus.
Your trials have a purpose.
Your trials are meant by God to refine you.
But there's one more way that God works through our trials,
through our patient endurance in the trial, God uses that
to display his glory to the world.
He displays his glory through our patient endurance
to the world around us.
The Bible uses another word elsewhere
for this idea of patience.
It's the word long suffering.
We don't use that very often,
but it's, it is a,
a very accurate term, long suffering.
Hear me, your long suffering
is a powerful apologetic for Christianity.
It is a defense of our faith.
When you suffer long, when Christians endure trials
with patient faith, they become living demonstrations
of God's sustaining power
and his supreme worth to a world that's watching
Like you are a example of what it means.
It's like it's evangelism through suffering.
And I think, man, why is my life so hard?
Maybe it's like, no, instead,
why did God give you such a platform from which
to speak about his glory and goodness?
Evangelism through suffering an easy life may not have the
best platform, but a hard life struggle trial
that shows the Lord off to the world around us.
It's like what Paul said, two Timothy two 10.
He said, I'm gonna endure everything for the sake
of the elect, like for the sake of evangelism
to see the gospel go to those people,
that God's ordained to be saved.
I'll endure whatever, everything,
I don't care, whatever you would do to me.
As long as people hear about the the gospel, man,
that's, that's a heart we want to have.
I'll endure everything for the sake
of the gospel going forth.
Because here's what, here's what patient endurance does.
Here's how it glorifies God at first.
It shows God's power, super na, your supernatural ability
to endure it just proves that God's in you.
God's grace is with you that you can make it
'cause people look at you like, how in the world did you go
through that and still have joy?
Only God? It proves God's grace
and God's glory and God's power as you endure,
it demonstrates God's worth.
Like you think about persecution, your willingness
to suffer rather than deny God is actually
testifying to his glory.
I, I wrote that and I, I thought of Peter,
you remember Peter on the night,
Jesus was betrayed the night
before he was crucified, Jesus was taken and he arrested
and he went through all these series of trials.
Well, there was one scene where Peter was like outside
around a fire with a bunch of people
and these people look across the fire
at Peter and they're like,
Hey, I, I think you were with him, weren't you?
How did Peter respond? I don't know him.
No man, I don't know that guy.
I swear I never spent any time with him.
I don't know who that guy is. What was Peter doing?
Of course, he was denying Jesus, but he was, what was he?
What was he want? I'm right there with him, man.
Like what was he wanting to avoid?
Getting arrested and getting crucified
like Jesus was about to get.
He was wanting to avoid suffering.
He was just saying, man, that's gonna cost me a lot for me
to stand up in the moment.
But listen, in the moment, he didn't see Jesus
as his most valuable treasure.
He instead wanted comfort to protect, to
Shield.
When we endure patiently, what we show the world is
that God is worth everything.
Another way it reveals God's character like
so think someone's oppressing,
think someone's bringing a trial in your life.
Your patient love for them
even when they're attacking you is an illustration
of God's patient, love for us as his enemy,
that he loved us.
We don't deserve it, we shouldn't be loved, but he did.
Anyway. When you take someone who's coming at you
and you love them like Jesus loved you, think of the way
that shows God off to the world.
Finally, it points to future glory like your hope
and suffering today testifies to eternity.
Remember, Jesus did say, you will have trouble
here, but he didn't stop there.
He says, you'll have trouble in this world, but take heart.
I have overcome this world.
There is a hope that is future.
There is something that we're hoping and trusting
and leaning on that is far beyond all this working out here.
It is future oriented
that only comes when we have hope in him.
Future glory, your patient endurance points to God's glory.
So hear me, unbelievers are watching
how Christians respond
to tribulation. So what are they seeing?
What Are they looking at?
How are, how are they seeing Christians
respond to trial?
Do they see Christians flying off the handle,
spouting off speaking negatively about groups of people,
like really angry about things, complaining about this
or that or the way the state of the world is?
Are they seeking revenge?
Are they manipulating to get victory?
Like are, are they seeing Christians act like that
or do they see believers with this joy
and hope and love in the midst of suffering,
in the midst of the world falling apart, in the midst
of all these hard things?
That is the response that can only be explained
by a sovereign good God working in those people.
The other way is the way of the world.
That's how everyone naturally responds.
This is only supernatural
and it makes me think of, of the first martyr, Stephen,
This Is in Acts chapter seven.
Stephen was being executed for defending Jesus,
for defending the gospel
and as he is being killed, he looked into heaven
and he looked at Jesus with joy, like
as the rocks are crushing his body, he looked up
and he had a hope in something beyond all of this.
He had a hope and a joy. His face was shining.
It says, and listen, you know who was there,
you know who was overseeing the whole
process. A young man named
Saul Who just a few verses later
was met by the ascended Jesus.
He changed his whole heart
and he made him into the greatest missionary we've ever
known named Paul
and Paul later records how he looked back at Stephen's life
as a formative moment in his journey.
So don't miss this. Your patient endurance
and tribulation is not just about you,
You, Yeah, you grow, you're in, you're refined.
You're more like Jesus. Your faith is proven like gold.
Yes, those are huge, good, important things,
but your endurance is also how the world around us
knows about and sees and understands who God is.
It's how they see.
So think about, think about the power
of stability in a world of chaos.
Think about how you,
you keeping your head when everyone else is losing their
minds, you're keeping your head how
that shows something very different
in your trust in the Lord.
And so just consider for a second how those
who are watching you respond to trials.
How do they see you handle those? How are they watching?
How will they watch you handle tribulation?
Are they seeing that Jesus is worthy of unwavering trust?
Even in the darkest circumstances,
even when everything's fallen apart,
the world is going to war.
Everything's falling apart in your family,
your body is dying
and they see you that Jesus is worthy of trust.
Do they see that and does your response
to suffering communicate the worth of following Christ
or are you only following because it's easy?
Do you see him as worthy again,
the struggles see the purpose.
It's how God is working in you.
It's how God is working through you.
So trust that your tribulation has some meaning
that he is not wasting your pain
and believe that the same spirit who strengthened Jesus
to face the tribulation he faced is the same spirit
that will strengthen you
to face the tribulation you're facing.
Lean into him for that.
Here's, here's the verse. Revelation 1412, here is a call
for the endurance of the saints,
the saints Christians.
Here's a call. Endurance faith in
Jesus is endurance,
and so let's lean into them for that right now for his help.
If you would pray with me towards that end.
I don't know the stories in the room right now.
I know some, but I don't know what you walked in here with
or or what you're facing at home, at work,
at your bank account physically,
I don't know, but God does.
He knows what stuff was suffering.
Feels like Jesus took the suffering for us.
So he's not some separated deity. He's involved.
We sang Psalms 23 earlier.
He's in the middle of the valley
of the shadow of death with you.
So in this, listen, in this as you pray, run to him.
Maybe you felt overwhelmed.
Maybe you felt like you have no hope. Listen, there is hope.
He's doing something in you
and he's doing something through you no matter
what you face right now,
and maybe you've just felt like
there's no way you can go on.
My prayer has been that today God would fill you
with his spirit in such a way that you can't help
but notice He has strengthened you more than you had
yesterday And then you run back to him
and tomorrow you strengthened more than you were today
and beyond as we go, until the day he returns.
And maybe you just need to acknowledge your weakness right
now, like two Corinthians 12.
Acknowledge that you're weak, but that's what he wants.
His strength is made perfect in that weakness.
His power is shown through our weakness,
and so just run him.
Take off the veneer, the facade, the the mask
of having it all together and just say, Jesus, I need you.
You are my hope, not this world,
not the things working out as it should.
Not that that everything is comfortable.
That's not my hope because that's so fickle.
God, you are my hope. And just believe that.
Tell yourself, remind yourself. Look to his word.
Look to the gospel. Look to the life, death
and resurrection of Jesus's proof.
Look to him.
He's our living hope because it didn't just stop
with the death of Jesus on the cross for our sins.
It continued with the resurrection of Jesus to defeat sin
and death, the ascension of Jesus to set up a future hope
for us and afu, uh, soon coming return for us
to be home with him forever.
That is our living hope, which means you can live today
with hope, With joy, with
anticipation of what he's gonna do through
the hard season you're in.
Do you see it like that? If not, just run to him.
Ask him for faith to believe it. We need that at,
Because Here's what James one 12 says.
Blessed is the man who remains steadfast under trial
for when he has stood the test, he'll receive the crown
of life which God has promised to those who love him.
That's what's coming for you believer.
That's coming for you.
Steadfastly remain in faith
Because Here's one Peter five 10.
After you've suffered a little while, maybe some
of you feel like that's a long while
after you've suffered a little while, the God of all grace
who has called you to his eternal glory in Christ himself
will restore, confirm, strengthen
and establish you land there.
Stay on that rock of him doing the work of him confirming,
strengthening, establishing you,
and restoring the joy of His salvation in you.
Run to him for that today
and sing this truth of living hope together.
If you're able, let's stand
and rejoice in that hope we have of Christ over all
and in all.
Let's sing for His glory.